madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition la valse des étiquettes
de certains médicaments des produits
dont les tarifs sont libres ils vont du
simple au double selon les pharmaciens
au parti socialiste dominique strauss
kahn est le premier à se déclarer
officiellement les quatre candidats ont
jusqu'à mardi pour le faire ils auraient
tous leurs parrainages dsk se présente
comme le meilleur rempart contre la
droite à madrid l'immigration somme mais
nicolas sarkozy réaffirme son opposition
régularisation massive de sans papiers
alors que l'espagne appel à plus de
solidarité
le permis à points pourrait être remanié
dominique de villepin envisage le nombre
de conducteurs roulant sans permis a
considérablement augmenté renault n'a
rien perdu de son mordant voici son
nouvel album rouge sang renault y parle
de ses indignations ses agacements des
chansons parfois vitriol vous l'avez
sans doute remarqué un certain nombre de
médicaments d'usagé courant subissent
depuis quelques mois une sérieuse hausse
des prix parfois même une hausse
spectaculaire il s'agit de ses produits
dans les tarifs sont libres depuis près
d'un an leur effet ayant été jugé
insuffisant selon enquête du magazine 60
millions de consommateurs on assistait
une valse des étiquettes avec des prix
qui peuvent varier du simple au double
selon les pharmacies et nicolas
chateauneuf depuis le 1er mars ces
médicaments ne sont plus remboursés par
la sécurité sociale conséquent selon une
étude de 60 millions de consommateurs
leur prix maximum constaté dans les
pharmacies se sont littéralement envolés
parmi les produits les plus courants
l'efferalgan plus 105% l'exo muc +1 26%
ou l'élu drilles plus 157% pointé du
doigt les laboratoires se défendent
certains estiment même avoir baissé
leurs prix
au final le prix de sortie de nos
médicaments quand nous les vendons aux
pharmaciens et équivalents ou inférieurs
à ce qu'ils étaient le prix pour le
patient a légèrement augmenté parce que
le pharmacien pratique de là dessus des
marges qui sont des mains jeu libre et
c'est son droit le plus strict alors
comment expliquer cette brusque envolée
des prix pour ce pharmacien c'est clair
si certains laboratoires jouent le jeu
d'autres exagère largement en
multipliant leurs prix par quatre
quant à la différence entre les
pharmacies elles s'expliquent par la
liberté d'achat et de prix consécutives
au déremboursement est bien clair que si
on achète un médicament à l'unité via
son grossiste répartiteur là le
médicament coûtera plus cher que si on
en achète beaucoup de dignité
directement laboratoire lorsqu'un
médicament n'est plus remboursé sa tva
passe également de deux jeunes lui 1 à 5
25%
mais ceci n'explique pas certaines
hausses spectaculaires des eaux ce qui
pousse le patient à se muer en
consommateurs avertis habitué à faire
jouer la concurrence pour trouver le
meilleur prix
dans l'actualité économique et social en
attendaient un certain nombre d'annoncés
amsterdam où le conseil d'administration
de ads est achevée rien n'a filtré pour
l'instant du plan de relance du
constructeur à rayonne aéronautique pour
se remettre en piste mêlant sait déjà
qu'il y aura la mise en place d'une
nouvelle stratégie industrielle avec des
répercussions sur l'emploi lors qu'on
parle d'un nouveau retard de livraison
de l'a380 patrice pollet il est beau
mais très en retard sur son programme
ce qui bloque sa fabrication c'est le
câblage en effet cent mille câbles
électriques serpente à l'intérieur de
l'avion boutabout on arrive à une
longueur totale de 500 km cette araignée
électrique va relier les moteurs le
poste de pilotage et la cabine passagers
mais voilà airbus n'a pas su coordonner
sa fabrication
résultat fin juin c'est l'annoncé d'un
nouveau retard à moins après rebus
rectifie le tir
au niveau du programme il ya beaucoup de
travail comme vous le savez suite à l
annonce des retards dus à un blocage de
notre processus industriels sur un
aspect relativement mineures en fait qui
n'est pas du tout technologique et pas
du tout liés au développement de l'avion
qui sont surtout les questions de
câblage cabine donc un problème vraiment
de logistique et d'applications
industrielles qui est en train d'être
traités restructurer les différents
sites européens
aller plus vite dans la fabrication
c'est le nouvel objectif d'airbus qui
emploie pour le moment 57 mille
personnes cette année le seul avion qui
devait être livré ne le sera peut-être
pas pour l'année prochaine
aucun chiffre mais annonce l'actualité
sociale c'est aussi la suppression
annoncée de plusieurs milliers d'emplois
chez psa peugeot citroën sont concernés
essentiellement les intérims et
réactions syndicales en chaîne à sochaux
la plus grande usine de france dans un
contexte particulier le marché national
de l'automobile fait grise mine jenny
briffa virgilia d'eau 5 heures du matin
en silence les ouvriers arrivent dans
quelques minutes ils assembleront des
voitures que peugeot vend de plus en
plus difficilement
ils le savent bien alors les réductions
de postes annoncées hier ne les
surprennent pas ça en fait un vol
présumé
ça s'arrange pour les actionnaires
j'espère qu'il aura pas de licenciements
forcés c'est ce qu'a promis une surface
mais non c'est pas un niveau nouvelle
pour nous des gens courant et puis comme
ça me concerne que des ce n'est pas des
licenciements secs en fait ça nous
inquiète pas plus que semble voilà pas
de licenciements secs mais des départs à
la retraite non remplacés et surtout
5000 postes d'intérimaires non
renouvelés sur le site de sochaux 700
postes d'intérimaires ont déjà été
supprimés en début d'année en raison
d'une baisse des jantes 6 au 10 minutes
nos programmes en objet aussi diminué
dépose de corey donc aujourd'hui la
variable d'ajustement qui restent à
autant plus beaux jours avant enfin
dépend du sens non parce qu'après il
faudra c'est ça encore plus mal côté
faire dépanner sentiment c'est le
personnel a lui même les trois quarts
des postes d'intérimaires visés par le
plan de relance ont déjà été supprimés
sur les sites de peugeot en france une
politique dénoncée par la cgt le
principal syndicat du constructeur
ça consiste à dire qu'on devra faire
plus de voitures avec moins de personnel
et les conditions de travail sont déjà
extrêmement mauvaise dans les ateliers
mais aussi dans les services où on
manque de personnel pour réaliser le
travail la direction de peugeot n'a pas
souhaité répondre à nos questions ce
matin son pdg s'est entretenu avec
dominique de villepin
le premier ministre a indiqué qu'il
resterait vigilant sur le dossier et
puis une bouffée d'oxygène tout de même
dans le nord où 630 emplois vont être
créés dans les années qui viennent
le laboratoire britannique glaxo qui
s'apprête à produire le vaccin contre le
cancer de l'utérus créer une usine de
fabrication marianne masse dominique
maes des ministres préfet sous préfet
député il y avait du beau monde cet
après midi à saint-amand il faut dire
que l'événement était de taille
l'officialisation d'un investissement
industriel jamais vu dans la région
depuis l'arrivée de toyota avec 630
emplois à la clé je ne peux que m'en
féliciter c'est pas un bonheur nous
étions en concurrence à une autre pays
dans le monde
c'est tombé chez nous à saint-amand je
crois que c'est à la reconnaissance
aussi de la qualité des salariés qui
sont déjà sur une partie du site depuis
quelques années le groupe est déjà
présent à tintin
avec une unité de 120 personnes qui
fabriquent des médicaments stériles
injectables
le nouveau site construit en deux phases
2009 et 2011 va permettre de faire de
saint-amand l'une des plateformes
européennes de production d'un vaccin
préventif du cancer du col de l'utérus
pour le groupe britannique
c'est une reconnaissance du savoir faire
industriel français on a confiance dans
l'avenir en france on pense que il va y
avoir de plus en plus de 2 de
compréhension pour le fait qu'on peut
équilibrer
d'une part le budget de la santé et de
l'autre la dynamique industrielle des
entreprises de recherche d'un aussi
pharmaceutique
les deux sont compatibles avec 14% de
chômage dans le secteur la perspective
de centaines d'emplois est plutôt bien
écrits sur sincèrement c'est très
difficile à trouver
même les boîtes d'intérim et tous est
vrai qu on a un peu de peine à trouver
comme il travaille pour croire qu'un
gamin de 16 ans donc on y croit comme il
faut voir aussi les critères qui vont
faire pour les embauches il touche
énormément
enfin ça peut être car bien pour pour la
région c'est le plus gros
investissements étrangers en france dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique depuis 10 ans
500 millions d'euros une vraie bouffée
d'oxygène
c'est demain que s'ouvre le mondial de
l'automobile grand public dans un climat
un peu morose nous le disions dominique
de villepin qui ne graisse le salon soit
à paris a plaidé pour un patriotisme
économique français et européens
le premier ministre qui a également
évoqué une réorganisation du permis à
points on en parle depuis quelques mois
il semble désormais acquis que le
système sera remanié jamais autant
d'automobilistes n'ont roulé sans permis
pour la seule année 2005 leur nombre a
triplé frédéric vion marie cros 10
millions de points retirés en france
l'an dernier plus d'un million de
personnes qui conduirait sans permis
faut-il donc assouplir le régime du
permis à points comme l'envisagerait le
gouvernement les conducteurs sont
partagés malheureusement bien l'épreuve
pour les gens parler
s'il n'y a pas la carotte au bout et je
fais pas attention à leur permis c'est
toujours un bouc n'ont jamais perdu
mérité ou pas non 75e 2 3 des statuts
je trouve ça assez commercial après une
poêlée pour passer un stage
commercialement en effet le permis à
points a fait la fortune des organismes
qui proposent des stages de récupération
de points pour en moyenne deux à trois
cents euros bonne fortune également pour
les avocats puisque le permis à points
comporte de nombreuses failles
juridiques et que certains conducteurs
préfèrent attaquer pour garder leur
papier rose pour clarifier tout cela le
gouvernement réfléchirait donc à
plusieurs pistes une possibilité de
récupérer ces points plus vite et des
sanctions moins importante pour les
petites infractions
des assouplissements auquel les
associations de lutte contre la violence
routière sont tout à fait opposés
ça pourra paraître dangereux comme un
appel du pied aux citoyens électeurs et
je pense que ce serait de ni bon ni pour
gouvernement ni pour la sécurité
routière en général
un assouplissement qui ne serait pas bon
non plus pour les vendeurs de
voiturettes sans permis depuis
l'augmentation du nombre de retraits de
points leurs ventes ont véritablement
explosé de 25000 l'an dernier à 60 mille
prévus en 2006 au parti socialiste c'est
donc dominique strauss kahn qui a été le
premier à se déclarer les officiels mans
candidat à l'investiture socialiste pour
et c'est chez lui à sarcelles qu'il
s'est présenté que le rempart contre la
droite
emile et lançant daniel lévy les médias
sont là et tout a été millimétré arrivée
solennel mais décontractée des
journalistes derrière les barrières et
suspense ni du symbole pour se déclarer
et dominique strauss kahn a choisi
sarcelles ville dont il a été longtemps
maire et dont il vante le bilan c'est
d'ici que je pars et c'est d'ici que par
cette candidature parce que je viens
d'ici et c'est ce que j'ai appris ici
que je veux être capable de porter au
niveau national et jeu depuis en retard
dans les sondages dominique strauss kahn
pense que pour lui c'est aujourd'hui que
tout comment s et nous sortons du
virtuel
nous rentrons dans le réel les choses
vont être totalement différent de ce
qu'on nous avons été jusqu'à maintenant
les socialistes d'abord les français
ensuite se rendre en contre je suis le
meilleur rempart contre la politique de
la droite
volontariste
et auto persuasion voilà de quoi motiver
les troupes et leur donner de l'espoir
quand je le vois comme ça à l'aise
déterminé expliquant bien où il veut
aller pourquoi il veut y aller je trouve
ça très convaincant je crois que
dominique c'est le plus compétent bon
j'espère que j'espère va faire un geste
pour moi personnellement vous demander
de voter le candidat plus apps et
dominique strauss kahn car pour battre
ségolène royal toujours favorite dans
les sondages dominique strauss kahn et
ses amis comptent aussi sur les
partisans de lionel jospin qui désormais
n'ont plus de candidat à soutenir
à quelques heures de l'ouverture
officielle du dépôt des candidatures
ségolène royal est en meeting à
vitrolles
elle est à la tribune depuis quelques
minutes elles viennent saisir l'occasion
de ce rendez vous avec les militants des
bouches du rhône pour annoncer sa
candidature à l'investiture
on écoute tout de suite ségolène royal
ici au milieu des militants et des
français je répond à ta question avec
simplicité avec gravité aussi conscience
du poids des mots et de l'importance de
l'acte
oui j'accepte d'assumer cette mission de
conquête pour la france et les épreuves
qui vont avec et dont je veux
voilà donc pour cette déclaration à
l'instant depuis le retrait de lionel
jospin hier matin la situation et c'est
sans doute clarifier au parti socialiste
les supporter de ségolène royal veut le
y voir une nouvelle bouffée d'oxygène
pour la grande favorite des sondages
ségolène royal qui a reçu le soutien de
pierre mauroy parrainage qui s'ajoute à
d'autres
arnaud beauté en quatre mots il affiche
la couleur
les militants des bouches du rhône
viennent écouter presque émue celle
qu'ils espèrent voir gagner pourquoi pas
une femme nous attend
voilà c'est le vrai break pour les
hommes la droite n'est pas le monopole
de la fermeté du sérieux je suis venu
c'est papon ni pourquoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle a devient parce que
les jeunes dans cette chronique d'une
candidature annoncée elle semble porté
par un mouvement de fond nouvel exemple
hier
l'emblématique pierre mauroy la soutient
avec à ses côtés une centaine d'élus de
la fédération du nord
nous considérons que ségolène royal est
devenue la plus qualifiée pour opérer un
large rassemblement dans lequel tout le
parti socialiste puis toute la gauche se
retrouveront lors de sa visite au
sénégal
elle avait dit qu'elle irait jusqu'au
bout cet engagement ségolène royal
l'avait solennellement baptisé le
serment de dakar
la favorite des sondages vient de fêter
ses 53 printemps en jetant l'épongé
lionel jospin lui fait un beau cadeau
d'anniversaire c'est une épine de rose
en moins dans le pied de la candidate
mais ségolène royal va maintenant devoir
clarifier ses choix ses positions
l'étape s'annonce décisive
seul contre tous la candidate à six
semaines pour convaincre les militants
et les quatre présidentiables ont donc
jusqu'à mardi pour se déclarer laurent
fabius jack lang ségolène royal et
dominique strauss kahn dispose des
parrainages nécessaires at on appris
dans la soirée
mode d'emploi de ce dépôt des
candidatures avec françoise des rides
les adhérents du parti socialiste à jour
de leurs cotisations au 1er juin dernier
doivent s'être manifestés physiquement
auprès de leur section pour pouvoir
voter
ils vont désigner le ou la candidate de
leur choix qui se sera déclarée avant le
3 octobre
les noms des votants sont dans cette
machine premier tour le 16 novembre
éventuel second tour le 23
le scrutin se déroulera directement dans
les sections socialistes union des
bouteilles sur place
les résultats remonteront au siège du
parti socialiste via les fédérations
pour se faire leur opinion
les adhérents pourront écouter les
candidats lors de trois débats nationaux
ou encore suivre directement leurs
campagnes pour éviter les contestations
la direction du parti socialiste
un gage de sa bonne foi il ya toujours
des imperfections parce que ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui organise ça
l'idée c'est de faire en sorte que
toutes ces imperfections puisse être
soit anticipée soit résolu moment venu
et avant le vote si possible environ 200
milles socialistes devraient se
mobiliser le 16 novembre pour un scrutin
qui s'annonce i need l'immigration
sommet avec à madrid de cette réunion
des ministres du sud de l'europe
nicolas sarkozy avait déjà ouvert la
polémique en accusant le gouvernement le
gouvernement de zapatero d'avoir créé un
appel
r en régulariser en régularisant
massivement les sans papiers ce soir le
ministre français de l'intérieur
persiste et signe il propose comme règle
commune
l'interdiction des régularisation
globale et veut intensifier l'expulsion
des sans-papiers sur un soûlard à madrid
au milieu des ministres européens venus
s'entendre sur le problème de
l'immigration clandestine
nicolas sarkozy a une nouvelle fois fait
entendre sa différence
il n'est pas d'accord avec la position
espagnole et réaffirmer cet après midi
son opposition à toute régularisation
massive des sans-papiers
la france qui en 1997 à régulariser 80
mx clandestins l'année suivante le
nombre des demandes d'asile été
multiplié par quatre on me dit on peut
pas expulser on t'a millions de
personnes je suis ministre de
l'intérieur depuis quatre ans je suis
prêt à accepter cette idée mais à l
inverse si vous dites comment on peut
pas en fait pas alors apprêtez vous à en
recevoir beaucoup
en 2005 l'espagne régularisait 600000
sans papiers sur son territoire une
politique volontariste assumé par le
gouvernement espagnol et son premier
ministre rose et luis zapatero mercredi
devant le parlement ibérique le chef du
gouvernement répondait aux critiques de
nicolas sarkozy
je n'ai pas de leçon à recevoir de la
france en matière d'immigration après
les émeutes survenues à l'automne 2005
aujourd'hui à madrid les ministres
européens espérer un consensus sur cette
question épineuse de l'immigration ils
ont finalement assisté à une passe
d'armes franco-espagnole
l'espagne confrontée au déferlement des
clandestins 25 mille ans atteint les
canaris depuis le début de l'année sur
ces îles où ont été installés des camps
de rétention littéralement surcharger
les conditions de vie sont très
difficiles comme le montrent ces images
gilles marine est un enclos bétonner en
bord de mer le camp de rétention die à
fria
capacité d'accueil officiel de 160
places en fait ils sont 1300 les
immigrés africains qui attendent leur
transfert en espagne par dessus murs et
barbelés
il s'adresse aux journalistes qui ne
sont pas autorisés à les rencontrer
monteil
vingt-cinq mille clandestins sont
arrivés aux canaries depuis janvier
dernier les centres d'accueil sent
submergé hook hendaye à fria les
conditions de vie se dégradent tellement
que ce sont les policiers chargés de la
surveillance eux-mêmes qui dénonce la
situation
ceux qui sont à l'extérieur détente
n'ont que deux toilettes n'ont pas de
douche et cela avec la bouteille d'eau
qu'on leur donne un autre camp sur la
même île lasri cesse 3300 personnes
retenues cette fois par l'armée caméra
interdite
les images sont tournées à l'insu des
militaires les autorités civiles sont
tenus à l'écart et s'inquiète surtout
pour l'image des canaris ternie par la
présence de tels lieux d'enfermement
situation n'est pas tolérable
bien que ne soit pas un camp de
concentration cela donne l'impression
que c'est en train de le devenir
et c'est ce que nous devons éviter yang
a tellement aimé ta légalement
l'internement de ces clandestins qui se
déclarent apatrides ne doit pas excéder
40 jours ci les autorités espagnoles
n'ont pu déterminer avec certitude leur
nationalité
elles ne peuvent les renvoyer et doivent
les transférer sur le continent européen
c'est ce qu'ils espèrent tous
à lyon cet algérien de 31 ans atteint
d'une maladie génétique très rare
attendent avec inquiétude que la justice
décide de son sort
compte tenu de son état de santé ne sera
pas expulsé alors qu'il avait reçu un
avis de départ à barr malek aurait
difficilement survécu dans un pays chaud
sa maladie n'empêche de transpirer
benoît guerrée olivier jacque la libre
après cinq jours de rétention
amar malek ne sera donc pas expulsé vers
l'algérie
franchement je suis vraiment heureux et
je me sens en pleine et joie devant le
tribunal administratif dernier recours
pour les sans papiers amar malek avait
il raconté ces années de calvaire en
algérie sa maladie très rare
incompatible avec la chaleur parce que
son corps ne transpire pas ils risquent
sans cesse l'hyperthermie chaque fois si
je peux me déplacer fait obligés de même
mouillé complètement bidon en protéger
pour que je puisse déplacer quoi fait
rare un professeur de médecine
responsable du centre de référence de la
maladie en france est venu défendre la
cause de ce sans-papiers en insistant
sur les conséquences d'un retour en
algérie le risque est un risque d'une
vie impossible d'une survie difficile et
à l'extrême un risque vital c'est un
risque potentiel rare mais dont on ne
peut pas dire qu'il soit nul
la 10 place directe aux dermit concerne
200 familles en france des familles
mobilisés dans cette affaire confie fait
à paris dans une école il a l'air
conditionné il a l'air conditionné à la
maison on peut pas prendre le transport
en commun
donc on voit comment on vit à paris à
lyon et on sait que c'est absolument
inimaginable d'aller dans un pays chaud
à 15h le tribunal a donc annulé les
expulsions une heure avant le préfet de
la loire avait déjà retirer son arrêté
pour amar une nouvelle vie commence
la mobilisation ne faiblit pas au
contraire pour aider les familles de
cachan plusieurs dizaines de
personnalités du spectacle du sport tas
politiques se sont retrouvés cet après
midi dans la salle du bataclan pour
parrainer 70 enfants une cérémonie on le
retrouve quelques-uns des porte drapeaux
de ce combat pour les sans papiers mais
aussi des nouveaux venus et manuel
bert régis mater moments de tendresse
pour le petit fodé camara jacques
higelin et son nouveau parrain bindia
elle se prête au jeu de la caméra avec
sa marraine la chanteuse diam's la
génération née on est métissé envie de
césar avec les autres 14h05 c'est en bus
que les expulsés de cachan arrive au
bataclan
parents et enfants tous 75 familles ont
quitté le gymnase
elles viennent assister à une cérémonie
de parrainage à l'intérieur les expulsés
sont accueillis par 75 élus the artist
pour eux
parrainé une famille c'est s'engager en
cas d'interpellation et les aider dans
leurs démarches administratives
l'idée c'est que les algues retrait pour
contacter le parent donne son numéro de
portable s'engagent vraiment accompagner
la famille et s'engage à tout faire pour
qu'il soit accueilli ici dans les
meilleures conditions
un parrainage qui semble redonner le
moral aux expulsés de cachan le temps
d'un après midi
considéré par un certain nombre des
personnalités
la zone b cette cérémonie est la
deuxième du genre la semaine dernière ce
sont des parlementaires qui avaient pris
les enfants du gymnase sous leur
protection qui a été international avec
les derniers meetings de campagne au
brésil avant l'élection présidentielle
de dimanche le président lula pourrait
être réélu et peut-être même dès le
premier tour si on en croit les sondages
bertrand cocq philippe ghislain sur
place ses adversaires l'attendaient à
rio pour un débat télévisé
mais c'est dans son fief syndicale de
san bernardo la banlieue ouvrière de san
paolo que lula a choisi de clôturer sa
campagne hier soir par un meeting
carnaval candidat à sa succession le
président brésilien est pratiquement
assuré d'être réélu
peut-être dès dimanche au premier tiers
les sondages lui donnent 20 % en avance
sur son rival un social démocrate sans
charisme
l'ancien ouvrier métallurgiste a promis
que lors de son second mandat la vie des
pauvres allait s'améliorer à pied à son
crédit l'augmentation du salaire minimum
et la création d'une bourse pour les
familles les plus démunies pour - lula
est un excellent président il n'y a pas
meilleur que lui lui c'est un pot pour
lui c'est un ouvrier ou la race et les
pauvres c'est le peuple travailleur à la
veille c'est un homme qui a beaucoup lu
et il va faire beaucoup pour les pauvres
mais la première présidence lula aura
aussi été marquée par des affaires de
corruption des scandales à répétition le
dernier en date en pleine campagne une
obscure histoire de dossier censé
discréditer son adversaire et des
valises pleines de dollars plusieurs de
ses conseillers sont aujourd'hui dans le
collimateur de la justice
il veut nous faire croire qu'il n'y est
pour rien il ne savait rien et il n'a
rien malgré les scandales lula reste
sans rival à l'ancien syndicaliste et à
son parti
les brésiliens applique aujourd'hui un
vieux dico de la vie politique
brésilienne roma est ce pas
ils volent mais il agit jacques chirac
est arrivé en arménie une visite d'état
de deux jours à erevan le président
français doit se recueillir demain au
mémorial des victimes du génocide
jacques chirac est accompagné d'une
délégation dont plusieurs personnalités
d'origine arménienne
un voyage qualifié d'historique charles
aznavour chantera demain soir pour le
lancement de l'année de l'arménie en
france en arménie où l'enseignement du
français perdent du terrain alors pour
tenter d'inverser la tendance
on retiendra cette initiative à erevan
une université française où les
étudiants sont bilingues avec des
diplômes reconnus dans les deux pays
reportage sur place
anne consignes et xavier luizet remise
des premiers diplômes de la nouvelle
université française en arménie
l'ambassadeur de france est là le projet
lui doivent beaucoup plus de 200 diplôme
reconnu à la fois en armes
en france et diplômes nouveau mais déjà
prestigieux
la famille de haïk a déménagé à yerevan
pour qu'ils puissent étudier l son père
est particulièrement fier que ce soit l
université française de cette faculté
savent qu'ils reçurent lombez notre
correspondant à leur niveau il n'y a pas
de discrimination pistons des pratiques
qui existent dans les autres
établissements
cette université c'est un esprit les
parents de haïk n'ont pas les moyens de
payer les frais d'inscription mais comme
il est premier de sa classe
ils bénéficient des tarifs régressif en
fonction des résultats
ils ne payent rien dans le cas on
trouvait donc temps de situation je
devrais payer quelque chose moi je te
ferai travailler moins mais dans ce cas
là j'aurais pas le résultat que l'on
ajouté que le dessus s'est adapté au
marché de l'emploi arménien et
paradoxalement pas besoin de parler
français pour être admis
quatre ans plus tard les étudiants même
nos francophone au départ doivent être
capables de pauvres en voir ça j'espère
qu'on aura un ensemble de jeunes
capables de dynamiser l'arménie de faire
partie de ses élites et qui eu des
attaches francophone
on construit leurs compétences à travers
la francophonie ici apprendre le
français n'est pas une fin mais un moyen
une approche originale l'université
française en arménie est unique pour le
monde de la francophonie et ceci nous
amène en france alors que commence la
rentrée universitaire une enquête vient
confirmer ce que beaucoup supposer les
étudiants quel que soit leur niveau
lisent de moins en moins une
désaffection pour la lecture socle de la
culture générale qui s'est installé
depuis quelques années partout en europe
daniel wolfromm daniel levy pour un
étudiant en lire un livre consiste en
général à se rendre en bibliothèque
quand elle est ouverte la grève peut
être une réponse au manque de moyens
dans l'éducation nationale mais tout
cela ainsi peu à la lecture publique et
le constat est là qu avant
oui
oui tout pourquoi
peut-être parce qu'il ya d'autres
d'autres modes de s'informer pour m
à la télévision
tu ne rêves pas l'élection ces jeunes
filles finalement
corrobore votre notre enquête ou pas oui
parce que curieusement les jeunes
sa 28e ans que qu'il dise moi olivier
postel-vinay est un observateur attentif
des milieux scientifiques il vient de
rédiger pour la revue l'histoire une
enquête sur la lecture en milieu
étudiant
le livre n'est plus ce qu'il était je
pense que ça n'est plus l'objet
d'ascension sociale par excellence que
ça a été encore il ya une quarantaine
d'années on a une trentaine d'années il
est d'ailleurs très frappant que en
france les étudiants
les plus brillants ou du moins une bonne
partie des plus brillants qui s'en fout
qu'ils vont faire je prends les filières
scientifiques au lycée en suis pour
et quand ce n'est pas fait pas
scientifiques sont ceux qui lisent le
moins de livres mais chez les
littéraires où les artistes
bref ceux qui ne sont pas forcément
obnubilés par leur ascension sociale
le livre reste 2 milliards dont la
soirée sur l'écran célia mais bon si on
imprime bas on n'a pas ces concerts ne
pas donc rien et après les lectures pour
on est un frein à la lecture
parfois le prix des livres j'aime bien
mais cela est une autre histoire
l enquête de conclure tout simplement
que le livre devenu simple objet n'a
plus le statut et le rayonnement qu'il
avait auparavant un atterrissage en
plein kazakhstan pour la première femme
touriste de l'espace la capsule soyouz
s'est posé en douceur à l'endroit prévu
et rose rouge attendait l'américaine
d'origine iranienne son mari étaient là
pour l'accueillir à new york un
anniversaire exceptionnel devant un
parterre très choisis et et célébrer les
120 ans de la statue de la liberté image
unique de la statue habillée par des
vaisseaux lumineux allen salvan art and
damned pour son 120e anniversaire la
statue de la liberté a eu droit à une
nouvelle robe un nouveau draper une
technique révolutionnaire la projection
d'une image grandeur nature 46 mètres de
hauteur tout de même en superposition
sur la statue elle même pas question de
toucher physiquement à l'oeuvre sacré
d'entre les sacrés pour les états unis
du virtuel rien que du virtuel et encore
c'est presque un miracle que le
gouvernement américain est acceptée
cette caresse lumineuse on a eu à faire
un examen de passage pour convaincre de
la qualité technique et puis du résultat
esthétique et après le projet paru
tellement magique que les autorisations
sont arrivés il faut dire que la statue
est un peu française cadeau du peuple
français au peuple américain pour le
premier centenaire de son indépendance
elle a été imaginée par bartholdi et
eiffel ses 225 tonnes ont été coulés à
colmar et transporté en pièces détachées
on a achevé de la remontée le 28
septembre 1886 il y à 120 ans jour pour
jour
et comme on ne manque jamais une
occasion de faire la fête à new york on
ne s'est pas privé le champagne coulait
à flots
sans oublier tout de même qu'on
célébrait une vieille dame pleine de
symboles
il représente l'indépendance et la
liberté
pas seulement pour les etats-unis mais
pour le monde entier c'est un très beau
cadeau de la france
quant au feu d'artifice il y manquait
quelque chose
ces deux tours là derrière le bouquet
final théâtre pierre palmade et pierre
richard un tandem gagnant réunis sur
scène dans pierre et fils une comédie
tendre qui réussit à merveille à ces
deux acteurs faits pour s'entendre
ce fils joseph dit dans mon premier tank
silloner de mon deuxième est distrait
solaire et plein de joie de vivre
et pourtant pierre palmade et pierre
richard se sont découvert une vraie
filiation
tout commence lorsque palmade directeur
de supermarché découvre que l'inconnu
qui vient de chaparder et son père
disparu il ya 35 ans n'a absolument rien
qui m'empêche appelé les flics
si oui donnez moi une seule bonne raison
alors je suis ton père ces bons
j'appelle les flics je pense que je vais
être content de le voir j'ai quand même
fait le plus beau cadeau qu'on puisse le
faire c'est de donner la vie
les dépendances à ana ana je te présente
je suis fier ont comme pierre enchanté
pierre donc qui est un oeil à nos micros
chat palmade livre la suite de sa
psychanalyse familiale qui se doit un
pam a de plus intime y met à nu ses
blessures
en parlant des relations amoureuses ce
soir son papa voyageurs au passage et
trouvant pierre richard
un père de substitution bah moi j'en ai
un
quoique
qui même s'il est parti tôt je vais
prendre et personne d'autre mais
évidemment ça que tu as peur quand rien
à voir je pense qu'on le préfère comme
copains que vaut mon père c'est ma faute
s'il faut dire les choses tout
simplement aux gens un sais c'est pas
difficile ça c'est de viser ça tient
rien merde monsieur directeur mais là
monsieur directeur nerfs de monsieur
d'ailleurs je t'aime mana je t'aime anna
sa maison pour moi dans la pièce de le
de lui faire éclater toute cette bulle
dans laquelle il s'est enfermé avec des
certitudes et des convictions et et moi
ça m'amuse bien de tourner autour comme
une guêpe epitech d'envoyer un petit
aiguillon par ci par là
pierre-yves fils la reconstitution d'une
famille pour le petit pierre qui s'en va
sur la route de la vie fort de son
admiration pour le grand pierre renaud
n'a rien perdu de son mordant voici son
nouvel album rouge sang heureux nous y
parle de ses indignations de ses
agacements des chansons parfois au
vitriol marie-hélène bono guillaume
viard
m
attention je déclare
pour renault les mots sont des armes
dans son nouvel album il retrouve toute
sa verve pour et sa révolte
c'est que tu es toujours comme un acte
de résistance
autre chef de chant sera moore à l'encré
noire classement
un album intitulé rouge sang uniquement
jeffrey rouge révolution au japon boj
dans leur gorge et d'amour du 110 m
haies mal où l'humain sur cette planète
elle a dix sept chansons dit cette
histoire pour raconter la bible dit en
passant c'est brassens les thèmes de
chansons elle n'a pas faim ni un intérêt
à 5 la vie l'amour là mort l'amitié la
justice le temps qui passe 10on et son
pote et pilou rossi avec les bobos
peinture de la bourgeoisie boel la
nouvelle classe sociale et il en fait un
clip
j'adore les inrocks
leur livre de chevet est sûre en du
catalogue ikea
saponé
le cinéma
ma soeur à temps
contre les maux comme j'ai pu lire halte
à gauche renault s'en prend aux bobos
attaque les beaux mots ça ça apporterait
d'une classe sociale avec un peu
d'humour un peu de d'ironie et puis la
pirouette finale est ici je sais aussi
partie du lot
mais bon
renou reste un poète avec ses chansons
d'amour
un amour qu il raconte sans pudeur mais
qui montre un renault heureux j'y ai
retrouvé le goût d'écrire avec du monde
à et des normes ainsi se terminait ce
journal je vous remercie de votre
attention tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet suivi du point route de
valérie maurice 20h50 homicide quant à
moi j'aurais plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13h excellente soirée sur
france 2